so uh i've been talking about this
for a couple of days now and i've been
tweeting about it for some time and i i
tweeted
days ago it's unlikely that january 6th
was the last riot or at least the last
attempted riot and indeed abc has now
obtained an fbi bulletin
which is warning all 50 states and
federal law enforcement
that armed protests are being planned at
all 50 state capitals it's expected to
start as soon as days from today
and run at least through inauguration
day on january 20th armed protests are
being planned
at all 50 state capitals and in
washington dc
um the if you've been following some of
what's been happening on the right-wing
social media
platform parlor you probably also know
that at least the language around going
armed this time
is significantly scarier and more
belligerent
in terms of weapons in dc january 6th
there are anecdotally stories and some
pictures
of what appear to be armed
insurrectionists
although um it it is not clear that that
was an
overwhelming issue on january 6th and of
course
washington dc gun laws are far stricter
than the gun laws in many of the states
from which the insurrectionists
came on parlor increasingly the language
about going armed
to the next series of riots is
significantly more belligerent
and to the extent that some of these
riots rather than being in washington dc
are going to be at state capitals uh it
is likely
that many of these would be
insurrectionists
will not only be armed at the future
protest but they will be armed
legally okay the fbi has also received
information about a group that is
calling for storming
uh courthouses as well as administrative
buildings
if donald trump is removed from office
anytime prior
to inauguration day or if trump is
impeached by the house of
representatives
or storming once joe biden is sworn in
which he will be on january
20th regardless of what else happens
between now and then so there's there's
a few
thoughts about this number one the
reality is that this
isn't we will do this only if trump is
impeached
or only if trump is removed by the 25th
amendment
the reality is that the the the
likelihood of this happening again
is under any circumstance in which joe
biden becomes president so
when i hear members of the republican
party saying we have to heal and move on
impeachment would be divisive it's time
to go trump reduced the the temperature
with his ridiculous
one minute video last week or whatever
um they
number one are clearly downplaying the
current threat level
but most importantly it doesn't matter
what the house or senate do
the terrorists supporting the q anon
garbage aren't going to change their
minds they're not going to stop
if and when joe biden becomes president
and he's going to
it is likely that we are going to see
more of this and that's horrifying the
only way that these people
don't do it is if somehow trump is
allowed to remain president that's the
only condition that they will accept
which is of course unacceptable to
society
it's incongruent with the law and it
can't be allowed to happen so
that's the reality there will be
right-wing violence if joe biden is
sworn in
there will be right-wing violence if
donald trump is impeached
there will be right-wing violence if
donald trump is removed via the 25th
amendment
there will be right-wing violence if
trump resigns because he will have been
forced to resign is the way that they
will see it so
unfortunately if there's going to be
violence there's going to be violence
merely because donald trump didn't get
another four years
they're not rational they've tied their
identity to donald trump
and trump is leaving and they're angry
they are irrational many of them feel
lost they're not interested in
governance or policy or the rule of law
and they've gone over the line and
turned to violence instead of respecting
our institutions
that that's it that's the full story now
we can pull in
how much of it is economic anxiety how
much of it is racism how much is
xenophobia how much of it is cognitive
dissonance or ignorance what role does
mental illness or in-cell culture play
great but a line has been crossed
where any scenario in which donald trump
doesn't get another four years
to some portion of these people warrants
violence and that's why
the fbi is now worried about
what looks to be likely over the next
week
so let's all be safe let's all be
careful
um and we're going to continue following
all of this as well as
what will the house of representatives
and senate do uh and mike pence
potentially about donald trump
i believe he will be president all the
way to january 20th at noon
uh we will have more of about this on
our instagram page
find us on instagram at davidpakmanshow
and you can also find me on instagram
at david.pakman if you are anything like
me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort
of your home it's a service called
steady md
they're one of our sponsors you take a
quiz you get matched with a licensed
primary care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays i took their
quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
they have a special offer only for my
audience you'll get 50
off your first month but only until
january 31st so make sure to sign up
soon
click the link right underneath this
video